they called saturday d-day when
protesters say the president and his
government would be forced to step down
and by the evening came the announcement
he agreed to act according to the
agreement by party leaders and step down
but because he wants a peaceful transfer
of power he has asked me to inform the
people of his decision to step down on
july 13.
many blame gotham rajapaksa for an
economic crisis that's made life
unbearable for many of the country's 22
million people
after breaking through barricades yet
another unprecedented moment the
demonstrators stormed into the
president's official residence in
colombo
inside this is what it looked like
the president was moved by his security
team to an undisclosed location earlier
while protesters ransacked his bedroom
and took photographs on his bed
within moments the presidential pool
once reserved for the country's top
leaders appeared more like a
recreational center
our government leaders must leave sri
lanka they can't govern the country
properly we have children and we're on
the streets leaving our jobs because we
believe in this cause we love the
country and we are suffering
protesters charged the barricades
outside the prime minister's house which
they then set of layers
rajapaksa's political allies know this
is a crucial moment for their party
anger is rising at the government's
handling of a die economic crisis
the worst in 70 years
the frustration appears to have turned
into a movement that can no longer be
ignored
in the end neither curfew not a freeze
on the distribution of fuel nor a host
of other intimidationary tactics were
able to keep the tens of thousands of
people away from colombo to drive the
president gotabe rajapaksa away
they say that successive years of
mismanagement corruption and looting of
the country's resources has brought the
country to its knees and they've had
enough
mila fernandez al-jazeera colombo